sion première question pour allez on y
va première question qui vous plaît par
tweet tiens hier vous étiez tous ravis
de l'arrivée d'axa tout dans balance ou
poste vous êtes à ce point hypocrite
alors la question alors dit la veille
qu'il veut répondre oui j moi je les
adore je dis toujours la vérité mais je
les adore j'étais extrêmement triste
pour elle qu'elle met plus de présence à
la télé je suis ravi qu'elle revienne
c'est pas de l'hypocrisie c'est juste
parce que je trouve que c'est très fort
milan est ce qu'on a un taux de cap qui
pense que c'est une mauvaise idée
avec moi et moi je m'en fiche que j'aime
c'est la bande dont cap c'est tout si
elle est là elle est pâle asséner ses
collègues qui trompe c'est une mauvaise
idée comme personne à les questions
suivantes questions suivantes allaient
aouicha merci benjamin pourriture
retourner shabalin m6 s'il te propose un
jeu en prime ou en accès au courant bien
au courant comme dirait la gare feu non
non on a dit la vérité
honnêtement non si j'avais une très
belle proposition tf1 s'est franchement
si ça vous tente pas sa maîtresse
m6 lui il faut pas de jeu mais s'il y
avait une belle peau quelques-uns
proposition s'il y avait une très belle
proposition pourrait refaire un jeu à
une belle place sur la grille en
parlerait à cyril et je pense que si
elle me direz soit des années soit pas
d'y aller mais pour l'instant je suis
très bien ici on éponge que je vous
tuerai peut-être pas non j'en sais rien
mais notre nation est suffisamment forte
vous le savez pour que si jamais ça se
poser on a parlé ensemble et benjamin je
vous jure c'est vrai je vous dirais
qu'elle est mieux pourquoi exactement je
rassure mais ça me ferait chier vous
partiez poils avaient obama ne s'est pas
d'actu et les questions suivantes
delphine si tu es tu es célibataire
jusqu'où irez dessus avec jean tu l as
pas jusqu'au bout de la rue c'est ça non
non ils rappellent bien ton mec dans le
public non il est lé retour tu peux
tenir
à chaque foyer coûterait alors non non
non non mais mais sincèrement avec jean
mis en plus c'est un c'est un jeu qu'on
a mis en place dès le début comme ça non
mais ce qui pourrait plaire oui c'est
pas parce que maintenant je sors avec
une personne beaucoup plus âgée que moi
il a quel âge votre amoureux il à eelv
avoir 53 donc il a 26 ans de plus que
moi mais j'ai pas fait exprès on n'a pas
fait exprès et mais ça veut pas dire que
gilles que dans le futur peut-être senti
un quelqu'un de plus âgé forcément
annonça veut dire que vous pensez que ça
va se terminer avec le gabon vient de me
dire oui on l'a perdue le gall s'est pas
directement la police forcément si je me
suis pas réveillé un matin
voilà c'est jusque avec avec roger on a
des atomes crochus et 7 s'appelleront
jours d'attenté les choses à la sepa le
gamin il a 53 ans mais s'appelle kevin
bougies en plus ça déraille
ils ont d'ailleurs ce n'est pas une
question d'âge c'est une question adapte
aux mains crochues et donc c'est pas
parce que jean mi a le même âge que
forcément ça va aussi
jean me satisfait de la réponse à nos
questions
isabelle touati hardiment critiquer mais
neil que penses tu des dernières
déclarations de marine le pen alors
est-ce qu'on peut les avoir parce que
marine le pen à feintool street
l'homophobie qui se développe dans notre
pays a pour origine principale la montée
du fondamentalisme islamiste belge à
nouveau être la seule à oser le dire
qu'on nous donne le nom des agresseurs
alors marine le pen déjà moi je verrais
bien moi alors elle n a pas l il fait
froid basse à ces législatives
mais là la ligne d'arrivée d'abord j'ai
pas vivement critiqué mais neil pardon
et ensuite que ce que je prends
déclarations de marine le pen je ne
l'écoutais strictement rien de ce que
dit marine le pen moi je peux rien à
penser ça m'intéresse pas elle ne
m'intéresse pas d'accord bastien qui est
en cause et des téléspectateurs voient
là et alors là la phrase sur
l'homophobie gel n'est même pas comprise
donc voila mais ça m'intéresse mais
alors absolument pas ce que dit marine
le pen mais non mais tu es tout tout est
elle s'est dès qu'un truc c'est l'islam
qui servait ça un truc de ouf c'est là
un coup moi
n'est pas aussi solide demain gilles va
perdre son ticket pour la laponie ça
c'est l'islam est un câble est alors
isabelle bon ça c'est isabelle c'est moi
est ce que tu sais où bozo taurine
missiles en plus j'ai vu sept huit
décennies
est-ce que géraldine et sur le dos cyril
aux malades ou les barrières c'est vous
dire
ça quand tu es de bisous que c'était un
bisou maléfique un bisou de d'halloween
ah oui un bisou fiction donc rien à voir
comment est ce que vous y avez pris du
plaisir
oui il a une peau très douce ils sont
très bons et bien taillée alors
géraldine c'est comme ma soeur bah oui
encore et dieu sait que oui les femmes
et tu sais que je t'aime énormément que
je te trouve magnifique mais vous aussi
malinké comme un soir un frère que je
vais te dire on pourrait dormir nu tous
les deux aussi laconique nous tous les
dons en laponie et là il se passera rien
et si froid dommage quand meme poker si
j'y crois pas vraiment frôlé texte en
son c'est pareil pour daniela et leurs
lots du coup avec tout le monde devine
quoi gâcher dubai paris alors quoi votre
kelly pareil à un blanc c'est pire que
les autres
daniel tu n'as pas l'impression de
prendre la place d'israël je pense qu'on
va terminer qui est à sion est là bas on
est là tout on est les femmes c'est vrai
vous est alors question est ce que c'est
vrai vous aimiez padoue faux début ce
fait une année ça c'est vraiment une
légende urbaine je sais que les gens
disaient ça
3 on a les mêmes points communs peut
être effectivement un jour vous vous
direz ça fait doublon en vendant enlever
une égard dit l'autre et et prendre le
contraire le garde les deux puisque je
dois réhausser la moyenne d'âge
à vous de merci mes attributions